Yeah.
Now music itself,
uh,
I mean the first musical,
first I'd have to give you an experience that I had that allowed me to see and
to all of us,
I had already been fascinated by the gods inside of us.
I concluded at the age of 12 that I was an atheist and if there were no gods and
they have an above us and know God's in the ground beneath us,
where were the gods?
Will,
my parents were trying to drive,
dragged me an atheist off the high holiday services and they were so intent
about it,
but I was literally holding onto the doorframe of their blue Fraser or by now
forgotten car.
And,
and they were shredding my socks.
They were quite frankly tearing my shoes off.
They were doing everything they could to get me up to the temple.
And so I realized in that moment,
if the gods are not above with the gods,
are not below,
where are they?
They're inside my parents.
If they're inside my parents,
they're inside of me there inside of all of us.
So my task at,
uh,
basically the age of 12 to 13 became use your scientific tools to find the gods
inside of us.
Okay.
Well you also,
again,
you elaborated on that part of the story that also made you a tune to those
ecstatic experiences because the case that you've just laid out,
or I suppose we laid out together to some degree is that perhaps it was that the
fact that you are isolated as a kid made you even more sensitive to the
collective belonging element of music because you were so starved for it and so,
and then the idea of the gods within that you just laid out seems to me to be
very much akin to what you described as either your tactic or your philosophy
with regards to PR for the rock personalities.
Because what you said you were doing was trying to make them reveal some of
these archetipal figures within and that that would,
and that you were actually trying to foster that,
which meant in some sense you weren't doing PR at all.
Like,
I don't know what the hell you'd call it.
I call it secular shame.
On us.
I was a name I was never comfortable with because it's so unscientific,
but that was the closest I can come to it.
It's like dowsing for the human soul.
Well,
it would have been a good name for a PR company.
A second.
Yeah.
But I,
I think that's a very,
well,
I think that's a very useful way of thinking about it because obviously one of
the hold overs from the shamanic traditions is obviously music.
I mean,
that's just,
that's just a continuation of the same tradition.